أعني أن لدينا كأسًا رائعًا
14 مرة في 22 بطولات كبرى حمولة كاملة من
الآخرين ، تعلمون أننا نفتح
ميداليتين ذهبيتين أستراليتين أولمبيتين ، هل أنت
مستعد للإعلان أو على الأقل
جعل الناس يقولون إنك الآن الأفضل على
الإطلاق  لن توافق عندما سألتك
في المرة الأخيرة ، فأنا بصراحة
لا أفكر كثيرًا في ذلك
ومن أعماق قلبي
لا أهتم كثيرًا بما تعرفه ،
أعني أنني أعتقد
أنه لا يهم أنك تعرف أنني  أعتقد أننا
حققنا أحلامنا ، لقد حققت
حلمي وأستمتع بما أفعله ،
نعم
أفهم السؤال
وأعرف الصحافة والناس
يهتمون كثيرًا دائمًا بهذه الأشياء
ولكن بطريقة ما أعرف أنني موجود
جزء مهم من
تاريخ الرياضة لا وهذا يجعلني أشعر
بالفخر بالسعادة
وفي النهاية
لا يهم كثيرًا
بصراحة شيء لا
يزعجني إذا
فازت نوفاك في 23 وظللت في 22.
أعتقد أن سعادتي ستفعل  لا يتغير على
الإطلاق
أه
ولا حتى واحد بالمائة لا
لذا فإن أشخاصًا مثل
ماكنرو ومات ويلاندر وآخرون يقولون إن
هذا ليس أبدًا هذا السجل
لن يتم لمسه أبدًا ولن يتم كسره أبدًا على
وجه التحديد
، فهل توافق على أنه من الصعب
أن أقول
من نفسي لا
ولكن أعني  لدي دائمًا شيء في
ذهني أنني أعتبر نفسي دائمًا رجلًا عاديًا جدًا ،
لذا إذا فعلت ذلك ،
فربما يمكن لشخص آخر فعل ذلك ،
لكن من الواضح أن سجل 22
بطولات كبرى أعتقد أنه شيء أه
من الممكن أن يزيده شخص ما
هذا الرقم  أنا متأكد من أن هذا
سيحدث ،
أعني أن 14 رولاند جاروس
شيء أقصده صعبًا جدًا بالنسبة
لك [موسيقى]